bitcoin is a hundred thousand in 2021 at
what point does bitcoins value become so
lucrative that bigger companies perhaps
battery companies look at this and go
hmm perhaps we can work our way around
this and for our technology so one of
the things I think really comes when it
comes to battery technology is everyone
knows that whoever can solve the problem
of storing power will have a massive
market opportunity and where is power
best monetized today one of those is
Bitcoin mining right if you look at you
know I'm an investor in a company that
one of my business partners runs that
essentially takes car tires and turns it
into a number of commodities including
power if you sell that power into the
grid you can sell it for three cents
four cents maybe five cents if you're
really lucky if you then go and you mind
Bitcoin with that same power source you
can generate 25 30 35 40 cents there's a
pretty material increase in the
financial performance of your power
consumption by mining Bitcoin for
selling into the grid even the power
companies are selling their power for
eight nine ten twelve thirteen cents so
mining Bitcoin is actually so lucrative
compared to these other power
consumption models that I think over
time more and more of them will start to
move in this direction we're already
seeing some of them start but I think
really when that price rises over the
next kind of 18 to 24 months is where
you'll start to see some really big
companies moving to the space look he's
got probably some of the best battery
technology in the market and you know
with Tesla if all of a sudden those
power walls either have slow sales in
terms of going to homes or he's able to
figure out some kind of industrial model
you know I'm not one to say that he's
not crazy enough to do it and look and
we know that he's aware of Bitcoin right
he's talked about it he thinks that
paper money's going away so he's very
aware of kind of how all this is playing
out again it's probably a distraction
for them in the short term but at some
point I do think entrepreneurs realize
hey if these Power Packs actually work
how they're promised they could store
power and I can use it to my advantage
to mine Bitcoin it wouldn't surprise me
somebody tries it and you're comfortable
then we've talked about the PR situation
I think you have you don't think you
have I don't have any PR is Bitcoin but
but I don't think that bitcoin is in a
bad place either
but I do think is the conversation about
sustainability and green technology
continues and we're seeing that more and
more even just in the last few months I
do think this is one of the things that
will keep coming up so you're gonna have
to keep her talking about this but you
are comfortable with the store of value
argument for Bitcoin here versus utility
value in transaction speeds because we
did touch on that a little bit in the
live show yeah so I think that store
value is really important that store
value before you can have meat medium of
exchange and I intimately the store of
value comes down to two things right one
is security it can't disappear it can't
be hacked etc and Bitcoin being the most
secure computing network in the world is
very secure right so we feel confident
there when it comes to price what you
want to see is over long periods of time
either you're preserving your wealth so
the price stays flat or continues to
increase the monetary policy of Bitcoin
relies on one thing supply and demand
economics artificially cap supply demand
increases price will go up right in US
dollar terms and so again if you zoom
out over the last decades the best
performing asset over the last 12 months
up 150% in the last you know what six
weeks or so it's up 30% so it's
continuing to do exactly what its kind
of built to do now there's high
volatility on an intraday basis and so
people looking like oh my god it was up
10% it's down 6% you know any kind of
emotional volatility in the last three
months will give a quick to that yeah
but but again people who put their
wealth and have a low time preference in
Bitcoin have been rewarded very well
with this store of wealth thesis and so
we tend to think that the non
correlation nutritional assets will
continue to be a valuable kind of aspect
of Bitcoin
especially when you have geopolitical
uncertainty or things like coronavirus
etc where the traditional markets kind
of go into chaos
you know bitcoins used to five or ten
percent swings up or down in a single
day out of trishul markets you know
literally people freaked out when that
happens and so I think that bitcoin is
I'm kind of better positioned for the
future world that we're going into over
the next couple of years then I knew the
trishul assets